hey guys my name is just today is the
18th of april and you're tuned in to
gamespot news ratchet clank developer
insomniac games have revealed two new
games at feral rights and the unspoken
feral rice is described as having the
exploration of zelda and the all-out
combat of god of war you'll be able to
transform into different beasts which
will let you use special abilities and
powers and the game features a combo
based combat system barrel right is set
to arrive on oculus rift exclusively
this fall another oculus exclusive the
unspoken will focus on PvP combat where
you attack by casting all sorts of
spells employing oculus touch
controllers to incorporate a wide range
of player movement insomniac also has
another game releasing in 2016 an action
adventure thriller set in Antarctica
cold edge of nowhere that one is also
you guessed it exclusive to oculus rift
Bandai Namco have announced to that Dark
Souls 3 had the most successful launch
day in the publishers history the
publisher said Dark Souls 3 is the
fastest selling game ever for the
company and had incredibly strong first
week sales although they haven't
revealed any specific sales numbers Dark
Souls 3 lost in Japan on March 24 and
does seem pretty solid reception
although some players have run into
issues with their pc version the game's
first expansion which is yet to be
detailed is throughout this fall finally
he be soft has said they will be
punishing division players who used an
exploit to beat the game's new incursion
mission falcon lot community
marginalized uppers who said using the
exploit was a violation of its code of
conduct so they're looking into what can
be done to punish those who exploited
the bug the current states that
exploitation of any new or known issues
or bugs is forbidden and may result in
account suspension or revocation the
glitch involves using a riot shield to
pastoral wall and avoid triggering waves
of spawning enemies the entire challenge
of the
curves and mission which allows users to
run the mission repeatedly makes loot
drop way too frequently and messes with
the game's economy some division players
have been speaking out on the official
forums and reddit saying that the code
of conduct is not widely available so
many players didn't realize they were
breaking it other players are calling
for Ubisoft to shoulder the blame for
the exploit even being possible you'd be
softer yet to confirm what the
punishment will be or when it will be
implemented let me know if you think you
be softer or division players are in the
wrong here and we shot ahead to gain
spot or we've got news on jurassic world
to and world of warcraft that is
everything i have you today that do let
me know what you cared about and i will
see you again tomorrow